there was a thing and I don't know if
it's true that you and Mike Myers were
not that close actually the rumor was
when he went off to do Austin Powers
mm-hmm
you were a little pissed off because it
was your impression of Lorne Michaels
vasee the pinkie coming I think he
coming right that was sort of your take
on well yeah I did I did do it
spastically when I first got on SNL no
one I knew was doing it right and I
first saw him at the on Wednesday night
picking the show I would get kind of
tense and they put the cards on the
board yeah and my first hook into Lorne
cuz this is one phrase right was lot was
Lorne saying arm I still have no [ __ ]
first star now he would bite his nails I
just did this he did that thing with the
pinkie yeah like that thing yeah and
then you know when I saw Mike do it I
did kind of go man but you know it's a
long time ago and I look it's a really
funny affectation yes because it's so
specific did you ever say to Mike hey
that is sort of my impression of Lauren
um I'm in therapy now I should say I
mean when you look back at it you get a
better perspective so we were like
siblings a little bit and we were never
meant to be a comedy team Mike just
invited me into the sketch but you know
I'm really grateful that he did and he's
brilliant at creating these constructs
and he did it with Austin Powers later
on in your career you realize how great
it is to have someone who cares that
much so when I had Mike next to me I was
always comfortable because someone was
really really working his ass off